un paisaje lunar en la tierra una isla
española en el medio del Atlántico sirve
de escenario para el entrenamiento de
futuros astronautas de la agencia
espacial Europea el motivo el terreno es
similar al de nuestro satélite natural y
el de martes el objetivo principal del
curso es hacer ciencia en la luna lo que
significa que nosotros como astronautas
Tenemos que salir y reconocer rocas
trabajar junto con los científicos de la
tierra para ver qué muestra necesitamos
tomar porque si Toma las muestras de
rocas la luna nos dirá como un libro de
historia abiertos sobre nuestro propio
pasado en la Tierra
pangea así se llama el programa
intensivo de geología necesario para ser
científico de campo en una misión de
exploración planetaria lanzarote es uno
de los puntos de aprendizaje que tienen
los astronautas para sumergirse en el
conocimiento de la formación de cráteres
y otras materias allí realizan
recorridos de campo y aprenden
astrobiología además conocen mejor los
cimientos de La Isla española
mientras hacemos el entrenamiento de
astronauta estamos también estudiando
científicamente la Islas las muestras
las pocas que tomamos son para explicar
más lo que eso nos dice de la luna y de
martes Más allá del trabajo
investigativo el entrenamiento de
lanzarote es un recordatorio de porque
el ser humano se interesó en las
estrellas
uno se convierte en científico para
descubrir el funcionamiento interno de
nuestro mundo y lo segundo es
convertirse en explorador para ir más
allá de los Horizontes y encontrar
nuevos mundos la agencia espacial
europea es uno de los colaboradores del
programa estadounidense artemis un nuevo
proyecto que planea reconquistar la luna